Họ khoảng hơn 2,5 hút qua bị sảo tháng 14,5 hút trong 3,5 tài đều khánh nơi,
đoạn qua 3,5 tình khánh hoa, đã sử dạ sật lượng.
Đất, đã sật lượng đã đổ chúng còn một xe khách phương trang đang dung dị truyền hướng
đại là khoảng hái, thưa điểm này có hơn 8,5 hút xe.
Đến sáng nay, thông tin từ sử dự khánh hoa, buộc sật lượng đã khiến sống người
tụi vong vào 2,5 hút. Đến bẩy giữa 8,5 hút cùng ngày, không tất cứu nạn đang cập nhiều
khó khám khi lượng nước, rất đã từ rối đủ vì lớn.
Hình này, tại khu khu khu tên á, vẫn còn nạn đến biệt mất kẻ sò đã đây,
một người bị thương được lưu vào lần trải gần nó.
Các sẽ kiểu hộ khu khu khóc lượng thực thực phẩm cho lời kiểu nạn khoảng 8,5 hút xe tụi nạn vẫn đang tăng cương,
đứt tụi cập nhé.